bonjour régis umpp et merci d'accepter
notre invitation sur arte france le
drapeau du mali qui flotte à kidal pour
quelle raison parce que c'est un symbole
fort super bowl inédit je dirais presque
historique parce que il faut dire que
depuis de 2012 le le drapeau le drapeau
malien ne flottait plus sur kidal et
justement elle avait été remplacé par le
drapeau de la coordination des
mouvements de la bad donc le fait que le
drapeau manière flotte et qu'eux-mêmes
et politiquement et que même la photo du
président manière fois affiché justement
dans la salle de réunion c'est la preuve
justement qu'il ya quand même un petit
pas vers la normalisation des relations
entre le pouvoir central et les
autorités de l'azawad juste moi qui sont
à kidal et qui pendant longtemps dont on
sait très bien que c'est cette autorité
contre le pouvoir central
on était en faction donc aujourd'hui je
pense que après 2015 c'est quand même
l'occasion comme de salluit il me
fallait ce geste symbolique il est même
allé d'optique il faudra aller au delà
de figer symbolique et je pense que
c'est il ya bien que dans les
commissions que le manioc et tombera
fillon ou une stabilité justement vous
parlez de petits pas vers une
normalisation de gestes symboliques
justement est ce qu'il ya un réel
apaisement entre les ex combattants et
les autorités maliennes
le ministre de la réconciliation il se
met loyers a annoncé que 400 ex
combattants rejoindront prochainement
les rangs de l'armée malienne
est-ce qu'il ya pas un risque là il ya
un risque et beaucoup d'opérateurs
preuve que justement c'est cette presque
une prime à la violence une prime à la
rébellion de faire des d'accord sur tout
avec lui ou les
des nationaux qui ont pris quelques
coquins qui ont porté les armes contre
contre contre le pouvoir central
aujourd'hui je pense que le mali a fait
le gouvenement le gouvernement il est
tel qu'il est aujourd'hui n'a pas
beaucoup de choix parce qu'il a
tellement s'est dit si vous voulez en
termes moins diplomatiques on parlerait
de compromissions pour le gouvenement
manière qui aujourd'hui est obligé quand
même de composer avec sa propre rue
bellion et quand on sait que justement
c'est très bien comme a fait plusieurs
morts il ya eu des tueries commun quand
même quand même car eux qui sont
innommable je pense que pour le
gouvenement m'aviez c'est une façon
d'avancer vers une espèce de
normalisation mais c'est qu'on est quand
même très loin de la stabilisation
on parle effectivement de 400 ex
combattants qui vont être mutés qui
votre mulliez si vous voulez dans une
espèce de police territoriale qui sera
fixé sera elle-même grèce et à l'armée
malienne
je pense que c'est un le pauvre a quand
même la progression des négociations où
le gouvernement vient ne l'a pas vous
pouvez choix et malheureusement
militairement et territorialement c'est
plutôt et les rebelles de la d'avoir
toute la coordination des mouvements de
la droite justement qui a le dessus sur
le gouvenement le grand mag et mais le
degré magnette disposition si vous
voulez de fête légitimité donc c'est
donc cette visite et lui permet avec la
cedeao avec l'union africaine avec les
partenaires extérieurs de convoquer
justement cette réunion est de permettre
maintenant sous l'égide de l'âge et les
pme justement à ce que cette crise est
gay qui aima vulgaire qui vit depuis
papeete lundi et mardi
place au sommet du g5 c'est le tchad
avec emmanuel macron ce sera par
visioconférence pour le président
français quand 8,19 oblige on annonce
également un message vidéo du nouveau
secrétaire d'état américain anthony
blinken à quoi est-ce qu'il faut
s'attendre selon vous pour pour ce gros
rendez vous il faut faire du paiement
afin que le gouvernement le guen le
premier le river et emmanuel macron et
anthony blinken qui est nouvellement
secrétaire d'état aux états unis puis
envoyé les jette mais fort et pour
soutenir davantage les initiatives qui
ont été mis devant parce que tu me plais
l'accord de paix d'âge et avait
plusieurs fois qu'il a été remis en
cause qu'il a été
bafouée donc le fait qu'il ya une
nouvelle avenue facture américaine et le
fait que le prix d'un maquereau fait
jette en game si vous voulez un peu dans
le bain ça fait ça peut donner une
espèce quand même de résolution mais la
véritable solution elle est mais elle
aime allier de la fermeture elle est
entre l'allemagne et de façon extensive
il faudra compter avec la fédéraux avec
l'union africaine et j'espère que
justement au fait ça me permet de g5 du
fait qu'il sera vraiment de questions
quand même de fait de cet événement rare
qu au conseil la crise malienne est
quand même assez dépendant de la crise
la fête du pain et la plus largement et
la bataille l'hôtel
merci rhji souper d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
analyste géopolitique et directeur
exécutif d'interpol conseil